world's largest rainforest is being
destroyed at an alarming rate
destructive fires tore through massive
sections of the Amazon rainforest last
summer and even before that it had lost
20% of its land mass to deforestation in
the last four decades for cbsn originals
new series
Reverb executive producer adam Yamaguchi
hiked into the rainforest and Brazil to
see what's driving the forest loss he
uncovered surprising financial
connections back right here in the US
[Music]
these agents from Obama an arm of
Brazil's environmental ministry say the
first step in deforestation is clear
cutting valuable timber whether legally
or like this logging operation illegally
could how huge they are the authorities
that we're following have said that they
routinely come across operations like
this deep inside the forest this is just
one step one part of the process in
seeing the forest team being dismantled
since 1965 Brazil has enacted laws to
protect the Amazon from destruction and
from development that threatens the
stability of its ecosystem and it
coaches on the land of indigenous tribes
[Music]
but enforcement is increasingly
difficult in this area of the rainforest
there is an average of just one agent
for every 25 million acres the Amazon
rainforest itself is reaching a tipping
point if a much more deforestation
happens the ecosystem would collapse and
turn into a savanna or a dry forest and
no longer be the rich biodiverse
rainforest that it currently is so we do
that well in recent weeks and months
scientists have said that we're within
maybe a couple of years at the rate that
deforestation is currently happening and
Adam Yamaguchi joins us now Adam good
morning so there are financial ties
between the u.s. and the logging going
on in the Amazon what are they
absolutely American companies are
investing in and providing credit
financial institutions are providing
credit to companies in Brazil that are
directly involved in deforestation in
addition we are a large and ready market
for Brazilian products of soy for
example that's grown on recently and
sometimes illegally deforested land
comes to the US and deforestation means
simply cutting down the trees there are
so many people maybe listening to this
that don't know exactly why this matters
what's the most
thing they need to know well I think
that it causes right as as one of the
interview subjects said in the piece we
are nearing a tipping point you know
there are still plenty of Amazon left
and that's that's what people sometimes
fail to understand there's plenty left
but you can only cut so much down before
you completely start to alter the local
and the global ecology and environment
around the Amazon so that's that's
dramatically dropping and and the other
thing is you know you think back to
August of 2019 some of the loudest
voices that were critiquing the
Brazilian government when it came to the
deforestation of the Amazon were
Americans and Europeans and yet our
money is being put to work to help some
of these companies do that very act what
surprised you the most in your filming
down there traffic jams and I'm from LA
I'm used to traffic jams
what kind of trafficked in my wildest
dreams imagine that I'd been traveling
hundreds of miles deep into the Amazon
and encountering at one point accounted
24 kilometres of 18 wheelers
nose-to-tail jammed on the road
transporting goods from inside the
Amazon to port cities and beyond it was
shocking and it speaks to just how much
is being hollowed out of the end zone
right now it's amazing it's not an
infinite resource no no all right up
thank you very much you can watch Adams
newest episode of CBS end originals a
new series Reverb it's called complicit
the Amazon fires and it is streaming
right now at CBS news.com slash
complicit